finance minister of our focus you met
the Germans mr. austerity in person
today there were quite a few friendly
words but it didn't sound like you found
a lot of common ground it's quite
natural it was the very first meeting it
was an exploratory meeting it was
important to establish a good human
communication and also to establish a
common ground when it comes to our
committed to European ism this is not a
bad way of beginning to start by
agreeing that even though we may not
agree now we must agree for the in the
interest of Europe finance minister
sheila was quite blunt about the fact
that he is skeptical that a number of
the measures that you announced last
week will in fact put grease on the
right path in fact he expressed the idea
that it could well be the wrong path
with all due respect to the finance
minister Choi bleh he hasn't heard yet
our proposals because we haven't tabled
them at the Greek parliament but he has
heard is a recapitulation of our
electoral campaign but as you know when
a coalition government is formed the
actual platform policy platform evolves
and I would very much like to ask our
German friends and partners and all our
partners in Europe to wait and see what
our actual government policy plants are
and then to pass judgment I understood
him to have been referring to measures
like rehiring public sector workers
stopping privatization those seem to be
measures that he questions well I
questioned them too if they're put
bluntly to me in this way let me give an
example very hiring of work is that we
have referred to do you know that public
schools in Greece now have no one
guarding them at night because the
previous government in its wisdom has
dismissed the school nights Watchmen and
women this is a fall saving because we
may save on salaries very low salaries
of these people
but then in the middle of the night the
schools get vandalized you mentioned
privatization we haven't stopped
privatization but our views and
privatization I are going to be tabled
we are not automatic we're going to take
each privatization on its own merits so
when it comes to the Port Authority of
Korea's when it comes to railways will
take very positive view wherever there
is an infusion foreign direct investment
that enhances competitiveness but when
it comes to fire sales of national
lotteries and other assets which are
highly undervalued and which are
soldered at the pittance and then this
pittance is thrown into a black hole of
unsustainable debt would be very
skeptical about that but I I trust in
the powers of persuasion way when our
partners listen to what we are actually
doing as opposed to what journals are
saying that we are doing then I'm sure
there will be common ground your
government has signal Greece's
willingness to talk but if we look at
the response of the European Central
Bank on Wednesday it looks like greases
partners are not convinced about the
actions you're prepared to take well you
see the this is a CB is our central bank
its central bank of every Yuuzhan member
state we respect its independence but
independence cuts both ways we do not
meddle with the central bank's monetary
policy the central bank doesn't meddle
with our policies at the fiscal level
and at the level of structural reforms
we are interested in pursuing structural
reforms to the fool and to actually make
them work in a way that they haven't
worked so far what the ECB has done is
to put pressure both us and our partners
to come up with a new problem the ECB
needs a program to carry on finance in
countries like Greece we must endeavor
as politicians to provide them with one
you have made an awful lot of demands in
terms of what you would like to see
Greece's partners and creditors do what
are you offering I can't believe that I
have made a single demand all we're
asking for is a little bit of time
during which a freshly like the
government can table its proposals
regarding the Greek crisis to them
we don't even expect them to agree with
our proposals the one thing we're asking
for is for the opportunity to discuss
them with us other members of your
government the defense minister have
used some pretty harsh confrontational
rhetoric when it comes to Germany the
defense minister referred to example for
to Germany wanting to establish a Fourth
Reich on the other hand you said you
would like to see Germany behave as a
hegemonic power that sounds like a
paradox well this is what happens when
you have democratic mandates that
imposed upon political parties
collisions you have won in this country
in Germany you have a collision between
the Christian Democrats and the Social
Democrats they don't see eye to eye on
everything and yet I have to speak
commonly this is what our predicament
here is to regarding my position on
Germany let's face it German is the
powertrain economy of Europe there can
be no successful euro zone without
Germany playing a very significant role
in my article that the earth referring
to I was making a distinction between a
higham onic presence leadership and an
authoritarian one the United States
stabilized Europe and put it on a path
of growth and prosperity by being higham
onic in an early 1950s which included as
you know that conference it included the
Marshall Plan I think this is what
Europe needs and if this has to be done
under some kind of miracle plan so big
it would be fantastic if we move in that
direction as opposed to the direction of
confrontation Americo plan is a kind of
marshall plan for now though you are
running out of money how much time do
you have when did the clock run out I'm
not going to speculate on clocks running
out I'm not going to indulge in the in
the art of spreading fear we're here to
seek common ground with our partners and
the only thing we're asking for is a
short space of time during which
deliberate as Europeans should
deliberate in this magnificent concept
of ours the European Union mr.
varoufakis you have one of the
hardest jobs in the world right now why
in the world did you want it you had a
great job as professor why would you
give that up I have no idea finance
minister of our focus thank you very
much for being with us on DW